歡迎收聽古歪,我是孟公
本期節目由Kiehl's CHEERS贊助
Kiehl's CHEERS 擁有超過160年的歷史
藥房起家,產品配方溫和天然
高CP值是年輕人的專櫃首選品牌
今天跟大家介紹四款產品
第一個就是CHEERS超級明星化妝水
金盞花化妝水
連續七年專櫃品牌第一名
能夠迅速降敏感,男女都通用
像我自己的刮鞍鬍子會敷一下
舒緩泛孔很舒服
第二款是11KDA超導全能修護路
用名神力小紅瓶
使用史上最小的玻尿酸
如果你的皮膚會長小粉刺痘痘之類的髒東西
擦一下就消很快
第三款是激光極淨白淡斑精華
超經典淡斑淡豆疤口碑好之外
能夠讓你的肌膚更透亮看起來更年輕
最後是冰河糖蛋白保濕霜
它可以舒緩肌膚敏感加深層保濕
如果你的皮膚乾泛紅脫皮
那通通都是可以拿用的
現在不管是從Kiehl's的官網或是專櫃
你只要下單超過1000塊
輸入我們的折扣碼GOOAYE
就再送你一罐金掌花化妝水40毫升的
那此外呢官网还有LinePay的10%回馈
Kios一直都提倡先试用再购买
产品适合你那你再来买
那现在呢你只要照全台的Kios专柜
出示我们古埃的画面
完成产品的体验加留下你的个人资料
你可以再额外的去领取4个明星产品的试用包
那这边提供给所有需要的朋友
如果说你是最近刚好要去振兴消费
然后要带女朋友出门要带老婆出门
或是呢你自己是比较注重包容的男生呢
千萬不要錯過這一次的機會
那昨天晚上我們還蠻期待臉書的發表會
因為Mark Zuckerberg在自己的臉書上面寫說
他們有新的東西要推出
我想說是什麼樣酷玩意要特別這樣宣布一下
然後下面很多人在猜嘛
有些人在吐他有些人在猜這樣
好結果最後面呢其實就是最無聊那個結果
我本來想像是什麼Oculus或是AR相關的新應用啊
一些新的開發還什麼的
結果其實就是Portal
那Portal這個東西就有點像是智慧螢幕啦
它跟平板又有一點差距
因為平板的功能比方說像iPad它可以做很多事情
可以剪輯影音嘛
那也可以玩什麼Garage Band
那同時也可以在上面什麼做詞做曲啊
做這個各種酷東西啊
或是說玩一些3A大作這樣
那Portal這種智慧螢幕它其實就比較像是
它就是一個螢幕
它主要是特化來給你視訊跟通話的
就結合Facebook Messenger讓你來講電話這樣
那比較特別是它那個視訊呢
那個鏡頭是可以去追蹤
就你在鏡頭前面走來走去的話呢
它可以跟着你这样动来动去
这可能是它比较有特色的部分
但是东西在台湾是比较少见
在美国是卖的还算不错
那它推出了两款
一个就是Portal Go
比较小的
那另外一个就是Portal Plus
一个是199
一个是349
就是智慧萤幕
那其实最主要
真的是让你来讲电话
然后讲视讯用的
那除了结合跟家人的互动功能之外
现在也会更加的去强化
这种办公室的应用功能
因为现在一大堆人在家上班
所以这可能就变成一台开会机之类的
那同时呢
它也结合了Amazon的Alexa语音
就是透过语音的方式呢
那你可以播放音乐啊
或者说请他打电话给谁这样子
所以其实就是一个智慧萤幕这样
然后他妈的在那边PO文
让我以为他真的要弄什么样很炫的东西
其他真的是一个怪卡
他之前在国庆日的时候
就拿着一个国旗在那边采浪版
我跟一般人真的不会拍这样的影片
他拍这影片其实就是透露了
他真的要嘛是外星人
就真的是什麼很奇葩的怪卡這樣
然後去國會的影片也很奇怪
就他那眼神空洞
然後看起來很像是一個機器人這樣
然後有一次去衝浪給人家拍到說那個
防曬塗到整個白白的很像鬼這樣
然後昨天要介紹Poro的時候也很奇怪
他的眼睛就左右眼窩兩圈就整個就隱隱的
我就不知道為什麼會是隱隱的
是防曬就只有塗兩圈眼睛還是怎樣
反正他真的很常做一些很詭異的事情
好啦那這兩天在美股群組那邊還蠻好玩的
最主要是因為禮拜一大跌
然後禮拜二就是AV盤
一下A一下V這樣子
大家很high啊
哇反彈了
然後後來又A轉了
這樣就是一直被八成狗這樣
那其實認真來說啦
就是在這幾個交易日
不管你是做美股台股港股
還是加密貨幣
你應該都是被八成狗
如果說你手上是持有多單的話
大家都在萌受一個獲利回圖
是一個很痛苦的過程這樣
那在這個過程之中
很多人就懂得享樂這樣
在美股這邊
因为其实两天的盘都不是太好
所以就开始有人就邀大家打德州扑克
那这德州扑克其实是像卫生麻将这样
卫生德州扑克
并不是真的有在赌钱
大家是玩一个虚拟的代币
那以前其实我就很常听一些
有在做交易的朋友会提说
其实打德州扑克
或是说打任何的这种打牌竞技
某种程度都跟交易有点像
但德州扑克可能是最像的之一
那有听过这个说法
我实际上去参与这个游戏之后
我发现真的很像
就我不是一个那种专职打牌的人
或者说会定期去打牌
我知道规则我会玩
我也没有认识去想过它
那天大家在玩
我突然就发现
然后在场边看
然后自己下去打
就发现真的是很像
就首先你先看这个牌桌上
如果你自己没有下去打
你很快
你站在旁边看
如果你懂规则
你会发现
有些人根本就是在二搞的
他就是下来
他把把就是他妈all in
就是all in仔
反正就是今天all in
明天退休
那后天就把持绳干在老板脸上
我觉得这种想法的人真的很多
那首先我们不知道
第一个他到底懂不懂规则
他搞不好懂
他就是故意要来OIN的
那第二个就是
他可能就知道
这就是卫生
卫生麻将
卫生德州布格
这不是真的钱
我就OIN这样
那也很高几率
就是他实际上就真的是要这样做
你不要觉得不可能
就像是一个标的
有些人真的就是不知道他什么
我听谁说
那个谁谁跟我讲什么
那我在哪个部落格看到
我就他妈满仓干进去
就真的有很多这样的人
他根本就没有研究
你说在股票市场是一个
聪明人把笨蛋钱赚走的地方
我这样讲我相信大家都认同
可是为什么有些人就是
你一个标的研究的时间
不超过一小时
然后你就敢把你的
毕生机器压进去
就很神奇
就有些人会做这样的事
那其实在牌桌上
也是有些人会做这样的事
就是他偶尔会赢
就你看到这样做的人
他是有些是真的就赢了
他有可能赢还赢两把
他不是只赢一把
他赢两把这样
那其实赢两把之后
如果说他懂得急流勇退的话
像我在那个上流哥的版上就看到
他说他有一个粉丝
那就是今年押到航海王赚很多钱
然后他自己知道他是靠赛
因为他根本就没有分析
他就看到很强
他就进去追了
他知道
所以呢他赚到钱之后
他就拿去买房买车
然后去做他自己的事情
他知道说
这个是上天赏我的东西
我要出场了
可是有些人可能就未必知道
他满舱干进去要赚到钱
那他就用同样的方法去复制去做
你要记得
因为你不是说什么
我从10万块进来赚到1000万
然后之后我一样
每一驻都下10万块
因为这样就是有做到风险控管
不是有些人就是
我钱变多了
我还是把把OE
然后你把把OE就代表
你铺险就是百分之百
所以你错了
你就是有可能
就全部就一次就拖回去
那你看这个德州扑克牌局上
就真的有蛮多人
在做这样的事情的
他可能赌赢了
然后之后他下次就全部就拖回去了
那跟交易是很像
就很多人正在做这样的事情
那同时你会看到高手
那这些高手呢
當然你不可能每一把都贏
就是他們會選擇一個可以打的局去打
就是你今天發牌是每個兩張
兩張是你的底牌
那兩張大家發一輪之後
就可能開始下注
先放底注
我不知道詳細的術語是什麼
反正總之就是大家先丟錢出來
那這過程之中就有時候遇到all in仔
可是你會發現說all in仔出來的時候
那些高手可能就先蓋牌
我就不打了
就讓你們去玩就好
all in的你們自己去互幹這樣
那如果說今天沒有人在亂的話
就大家都是先把底柱出完
那庄家就会放牌在桌上
好像是先放两张吧
放两张牌在桌上
那之后你就要去看
这个你的牌跟桌上的牌
好像两张还是三张忘记了
反正就是你的牌跟桌上的牌
是不是可以组出什么样的东西吗
如果是这个pairs
就是如果是对子
还是说是什么童话
还是顺子
还是说什么的
反正如果说你组了出东西的话
那就代表说
这个你的胜率就变高了
那你就会发现呢
这些高手呢
他可能就在过程之中
慢慢的去加注
那他也未必会
比方说他今天就算是拿到很好的牌
因为我们可以用上帝视角
看到他拿到很好的牌
他也不会直接他妈就是all in干进去
他可能就是慢慢的故意调你
要慢慢加
让大家都上车之后
然后一直来个大的
那大家可能觉得
干我都来都来了
我钱都付了
就跟牌这样
所以其实某种程度也是在比
一个心理的战争的感觉
我觉得是跟投资有点像
但是这个心理战争的部分
可能比较难一点
因为我们在股票市场
就是看这个ticker在跳
你就是看这个五党报价
那美股的话可能就是不止五党
就好几档的报价这样跳来跳去
你可能未必知道
就是每个人的感受或什么
因为那就是一个纯粹的数字而已
可是有些人
当然他也可以从这数字里面
就感受到别人的情绪
那是可能是很进阶很进阶的交易者
但是在这个加码的过程
我觉得就很像
就是高手呢
他拿到他的牌
首先他就会评估说
这牌可不可以打
如果说这牌根本就是
他觉得烂牌
要嘛就是可能花色差太多
这个间隔隔太远之类的
他觉得根本就没有必要
打他直接盖牌了
所以他在过程之中
可能就是赔掉他这个抵住的钱
抵住的钱慢慢的这样消耗掉
没关系
重点就是他只要可以活得够久
他只要可以拿到一次对的牌
他可能就可以一次把
他前面的这个震荡的成本
全部就把他给抓回来这样
那我觉得我看的这个过程之中
就跟我自己在做买卖有点像
那先强调一下
就是其实交易跟投资
基本上那是两个范畴的东西
基本上交易人会比较注重于
每次买进的成本跟价格
以及之后是不是有按照自己的想法
去做变化
就是你是不是
你做空就是他就是要跌
他如果没有跌的话
我就不会打跌而住
交易的人可能会这样想
但是如果你今天做投资的人
他可能想法是完全不一样的
据理来说他今天看了一个标的
标的目前价格是100块
实际上他算也算
他觉得内在价值应该是200
也就是说目前的价格是被低估了
所以他可能就会愿意买进
就是他算一个安全边际
如果说是目前价格是100
80块我就买
再抓个20%的安全边际
就再保守一点
即便我知道他可能值200块
那他跌到80%就要可能开始买
然后之后跌到60%他也买
50%他也买
这可能是投资人会做的事情
就那种比较纯血的价值投资会这样做
但是交易人一般来说他就不会这样做
他可能不会希望说他买进然后马上就被套
那这可能一开始跟大家讲大家都听不懂
可是我发现如果你用扑克牌的例子去讲
可能大家就听得懂了
也就是如果你今天拿到手上的这两张牌
就有点像是你今天找了一个标的
那当然这个标的研究深跟广
到底是多深多广
那因人而异嘛
可是你就把它想象成
就是我们都看到了
自己手上现在有一个标的这样
那很少人会在第一柱
就是我看到标的的这个
一瞬间我就选择all in
就只有那些all in仔会这样做嘛
可是其他人呢
就是慢慢来
我先打底柱这样
那我发现最后面
胜率是站在我这边
我发现这个牌子
往我要的方向去
我才会开始去加注
这其实就跟
像我自己的交易逻辑很像
我比较少讲这个
因为这种短线的东西
我觉得讲的可能会害人
所以我很常去loop说什么
叫你去做指数投资
然後跟大家講一些市場的東西
那沒關係我下去跟大家講一點
我自己實際上在短線上的做法會是怎麼樣
基本上我不太會去做這種all in的事情因為我曾經吃死過任何有吃死過的人應該都知道就是你OIN的一個就算你做了很多的研究連股東會都跑去開了可是就是有太多這種事與願為的事情
就算是你真的把財報全部都掃完
然後你全部都對
你全部都看對
可是財報是假的
他根本這公司就在做假
那你一樣就中槍這樣
因為你有遇過這樣的事情
你就知道你絕對不可以OIN
所以你基本的分散是要有的
當然你也不用說
100萬分散到50支
那你不如直接去買ETF
就可能分散到什么三五支之类的
这应该是蛮多人都会这样做的
那好 举例来说
我今天就分散到三支好了
那这个资金的配额呢
是30 30 40
这样来说好了
那举例来说
我现在就是看到了这一支
我要丢30万的标的
我绝对不会再递住
就是我今天看到它
那估值好 算好了
这个价格是OK的
那我就直接把30万全部打进去
我不会这样做
因为你根本不知道
明天会发生什么事情
就像是你在上礼拜五
你知道上礼拜五台股其实超乐观的
你根本没有想到
然後禮拜一會直接這樣跳囉
就是有時候那理由就是自己硬要亂找的你知道嗎
就是恆大事件一整年的
為什麼在台股跟美股一直在創新高的時候
沒有人要講恆大
然後真的跌的時候大家就說罵恆大害的
那你知道其實在去年有比恆大更大的嗎
叫華融
這個中國華融資產管理
那這個泡泡甚至比恆大更大
可是為什麼沒有人要講
這個當然是最後面被黨中央給
就是基本上把他算是敲掉了
還有一些餘危還沒有發生
但是他有去做處理
當股市在漲的時候就沒有容易找藉口
可是當下跌的時候大家就會找藉口
其實你找藉口本身沒有問題
你當然可以找藉口
就像法人也會找藉口
你可能很多人不知道
如果你說你今天有認識會待交易室的
我們說這些比方說這個投信好了
他們今天如果看到他們手上的標的大底
他第一件事情也是馬上摳朋友
可能就是發個line或什麼的
大家趕快問一下發生了什麼事情
是有人肥手指還是有什麼事情我不知道的
大家趕快了解一下
會這樣
那這就是找理由的一種
但是另外一種找理由
就是一般散戶
其實一般散戶
因為你資訊掌握度
本來就輸人家了
那就算你今天找到一個
你覺得好像就是
因為這個理由而跌的
So what
因為你最後面的目的
還是你要賺錢
所以我現在該怎麼辦
重點是我要怎麼處理
就像是你班上
或是去工作的時候
同事一定就會有很多那一種
他很會指出大家的問題
可是他永遠不會去解決問題
你真的叫他做事情
他沒辦法
他只會把大家的問題指出來
他沒有行動力的
那你今天就算你找了这个理由
那就算这个理由
真的就是法人也这样觉得好了
那重点是什么
重点是你要怎么做
你要加码你要减码
还是说你要
就是我盖牌我不玩了
我要直接全部出掉
那这其实就跟这个打牌
是有点像的
就当你在掌握更多的资讯
然后你确定
你看的这个方向是对的
什么叫看的方向是对的
就是至少你的地柱是赚钱
或者说你
因为你觉得这个牌
它可以组出很好的牌
所以我才会在地柱
这个底柱先出
然后之后人家加
我跟着加
因为我发现
那个公牌开出来
跟我东西好像可以组出什么
我才会去加
所以在交易上
就很像是我今天
第一批单打进去
然后它涨了
基本上在市场上
我们就讲白一点
你用各种方法去分析什么的
都OK
但是最终
大多数人进来
就是要赚资本利得
你就要赚这个价差
也就是说你要出货给下一个
萌新
下一个傻逼在你后面的
然后他可能看到这个好
他还追进来的
我们的目的是这样
就讲白一点
就是这样子
所以往你要的方向去走
是很重要的
当我今天打进第一单
我就是要看到
他要往我的方向去走
我才有可能会去做加码
只有在一些比较少数的案例
举例来说
以我自己上乎发生的
就是在这个NVIDIA
NVIDIA大跌的时候
我敢减
因为我知道这家公司够强
我真的知道
所以就算我看错
假设这个NVIDIA
突然就他妈就倒掉
我就认了
因为我也没有说什么
我就all in压他
我也是有做好资金的控管
所以我可以去承担这样的风险
我会去做这样子
就比方说明明是我上一单是比这个更高
就是我是套在山上的
然后我还去摊平
这个是在比较少的案例会这样做
可是大多数的案例
特别是以我自己在台湾做供应店
我一定会确保我的第二单要比我的第一单来的
就是一定要涨上去了
等于说我第二单一定要买的比第一单贵
那有些人会不懂这个
他想说那你为什么不要第一单就直接满舱干进去就好
那我反而会想问你
你怎么知道它一定会涨
它搞不好是跌啊
你知道其实有很多东西是
你觉得它很好
可是市场不认同啊
像今年的苹概股跟苹果
你说苹果是因为托拉斯
是因为各国政府要去搞它
要去把它的支付税给拆掉
它跌OK
那你说做硬体的呢
本来大家说iPhone 13不好卖
就iPhone 13在中国在台湾
评价超好
然后一堆人在抢
甚至抢不到
那硬体商照来说是要获利
供应链你看营收开出来
是真的有开出来
可是为什么股价一直跌
为什么后来投信气首
法轮不玩的
公司真的有赚钱啊
可是在交易呢
其实并不是那么单纯
就是你只是单纯看一家公司
基本面好
他就等于一定会长
没有这种事情
就像我们可能会看到一些人
他明明就应该值得更好的人
可是为什么
就是他妈跟他在一起都是渣男
就有些东西你真的没有办法解释
搞不好对
他就喜欢渣男之类的
或者是他就是运气不好
他身边真的就没有那样的人
那在市场的这个标的也是一样
就这个东西你觉得他很好
那他可能最后面就是
不会获得市场的资金清代
他营收真的有开出来
获利也有开出来
但是就长不上去
这样的例子台股有
其实在港股更多
其实像港股一大堆那种
你用本益笔看
哇操这已经来到历史超级低一点了
但是为什么就是一直跌
就市场资金就是不完的
那我们终究的任务是要出给下一手
所以当市场资金不完
其实基本上你某种程度
也是要去尊重这个趋势
就是如果说以前的港股
举例来说
这本益笔可以称在
我们随便举例一个数字
15好了
那现在就变成只能称在5
你也只能认
难不成就是
因为5真的是比之前便宜
所以我就借更多钱一直去买
那你就发现它就连续连年下跌
即便它状况没有很差
可是它就连年下跌
但是我这样的举例
我自己知道
就是不是每一个
举例来说新手
甚至是什么中手老手
都听得进去
因为可能在过程之中
他就觉得
我就是真的很会做到价值发现
我真的可以每次买
然后我买的东西最后都会涨
那恭喜你
可是如果说你有那种
遇人不熟的经验
就是你买进去
然后发现这东西真的没有搞头
什么的
其实你要记得
如果说你都有做好资金的控管
其实真的是很难一次毕业
举例来说你都没有在做杠杆
你都没有借钱
你不是借钱上这个牌桌的
当然你的出发点就比别人强
第一个你心态一定比别人强
因为你不是借钱的
所以你可能比较可以容许
就是我有看错的时候
那第二个呢
就是如果说我每一次下注
我都会坚守一个纪律
举例来说
因为现在很多人毕业
其实就是你就是中压乱搞
那如果说你现在手上
我们讲真的有100万
我们讲的最保守最保守的
你一个标的就是不会买超过10万块
你最多就是买10万块
那其实你这样子要毕业的几率
就已经是远低于那一种
他可能100万压一支标的的
已经远低于那样了
就是有时候其实你东西是看对
可是因为他的震荡太大了
他的波动太大了
所以你受不了你就砍了
像可能以现在台股来讲
我必须得说
很多的IC设计已经跌到
跟他妈价值股一样
本益比在10到15之間
那已經算是歷史的低檔了
當然你有時候會講說
這可能是因為台股今年真的太旺了
基期超高
明年未必這麼好
但是有些我自己看
我覺得可能明年還是會很好的
那現在真的便宜了
只是它的波動就很大
就是你買進去你覺得它夠便宜
就幹它還可以再跌
那可能因為你資金是一次幹進去
你就受不了你就把它砍了
所以你就直接就實現虧損了
所以如果說你可以把這個
打牌的這個加碼
就是你先去玩看看德州撲克
然后你把这个打牌的加码
应用在交易里面
其实你会瞬间理解很多东西
你会发现你之前很多操作是鬼打墙
就一大堆人就是
我第一单就打进去
我根本没有加减码的概念
对他来说只有0跟1
要嘛就是all in
要嘛就是all out
其实这是一个很错误的观念
如果说你可以去理解
就是部位是用百分比来算
就是0到100%
你是可以用0到100%去调整
而不是0跟1
就是你只能够要嘛all in all out
你是可以用带状去调整
你是由子弹去打的
其实在整个这个买卖的过程之中
你甚至会发现
你并没有变得更聪明
你不是说什么基本面变强了
消息变多了
然后怎么像我这样录了一个podcast之后
开始他妈的获得一大堆消息来源
赞赞赞这样
然后绩效变好什么的
就是你未必有获得这样的一个新的东西
新的input
你只是单纯的去把你的策略改变
从本来all in all out变成
带状加码带状离场
然后你就很惊喜的发现
我干嘛干那绩效变好了
因为这东西我会愿意这样跟大家讲
也说敢这样跟大家讲
是因为就是身边有些朋友这样点他之后
就真的就绩效变好了
因为其实你如果真的每次都要想成是
这个东西只能够中仓
或是整个砍仓的话
在过程之中
特别是市场有很多这种魔人的时刻
你往往就会砍在一个阿呆鼓
或说你会追在一个山顶上
因为你会怕错过
你会FOMO
那FOMO可能现在大家比较少听到
在去年我们很常讲到FOMO
就是你很怕错过
这个fear of missing out
所以你就
看那个标的
都赶快直接追上去
那今年反而不一样
今年是很怕说
你买了就被升套
所以你发现这两年市场
就开始有做一些变化了
去年可能这个
到今年中
可能疯狗流是市场的主流
反正什么东西强势
我就追
但今年
如果说你从6月开始
在追强势的
应该是很痛苦
很痛苦
但也不是说什么
追强势的策略就死了
没有
它搞不好就是等到
下个循环会重新的回来
但如果其实
不管是
市况是长怎么样
但是你有谨记
就像你去打牌这样
你不可能第一柱就当欧印宅
你一定是试着慢慢夹这样
然后如果说你混合一点
这种交易的逻辑进去
你基本面你也是了解的
然后你打进第一单之后
你发现你现在是
这个第一单是被套了
那除非你很有自信
像我刚才讲
你很有自信
你就去做探品
如果说你没有自信
那我就等待
我就等待他回来之后再说
如果你是这样做的话
你会发现
你可能了不起在市场里面
被套的部位
或是目前破险的部位
它是有限的
就不会像你可能过往
就是要嘛就是
干这是满手股票
然后套在山顶上
就是那个差距
马上就拉出来了
所以我确实是在
昨天跟前天
就是跟大家玩
那个德州扑克之后
因为我自己
也没有认真去想这件事情
那我知道最近
好像有一个蛮红的
就是被深红找去录节目
那个在讲扑克的
所以一瞬间好像变得
蛮多人在讨论扑克的
突然可能大家
也想要打扑克之类的
然后我可能也是
看到了这样的东西
就我可能平常看到
如果有人在群组
贴德州扑克
我可能也不会受到影响
我先讲说
有些电影会这样拍
就是你要去引导一些人的作为
你就是在他的视觉范围内
一直去给他cue
就是给他一个暗示
所以我可能也是看了很多这样的东西
其实我那天才会跟着点进去打德州扑克
他妈小孩不照顾
干跑去打德州扑克
但也在这个过程之中就发现
确实朋友们讲的是对的
他跟我们在买卖上
是真的有很多类似的地方
所以如果说你可以把这个想法给
当然也不是说什么融会贯通
因為我覺得投資本身就是一個終身學習的東西
就到現在都還是會有時不時會犯錯這樣只是犯的錯不會錯到就是我可能會造成一個致命性的危機其實我現在回頭看我會發現我過往有些犯錯是真的幹他媽 歐彌陀佛還好我沒有畢業
就是我過往那種什麼滿艙槓桿啊什麼
那都是非常高機率
就是如果當時真的出事情的話
我現在就完全不會在這裡了
或是其實我回想我國中也是這樣
因為我們苗栗長大嘛
那國中
幹那時候
其實真的講小孩要帶好
特別是那種鄉下的地方
那苗栗我覺得就很明顯
我們同學一大堆在那邊拉K
去上KTV就在裡面拉K這樣
那邊吸塑膠
認真講當時你的戒心很低
就如果我朋友在那邊
來啦來啦拉一下啦
你可能就真的就跑去拉一下
那我有時候就會想說
如果當時去拉一下
我現在搞不好就不在這
就是我很多東西就改變了
或是如果那時候朋友酒駕
你跟著去酒駕
你現在你就不在這了
所以我真的說
可能就是我們閱讀
或是去比方說你收聽Podcast
或是看一些別人的經驗
我覺得最大的收穫就在這邊
你知道其实很多人误解一件事情
就是有些论坛会惦我
你知道吗
古外讲的东西这么浅
不是啦
你真的以为你他妈的看YouTube
或是听Podcast
还是什么翻哪本书
你就会变投资天才
干吃点肉
那一定是要进市场磨练的
就是你在别人身上听的
不是说你听的人就变投资天才
你有这个认知
你本身就有问题
其实你要听就是听人家的一些
就是他可能跟你讲
他遇过的事情或什么的
当然你未必会遇到
可是如果你在人家讲的这100个故事里面
你他妈你捞到几个
然后你下次遇到雷同的状况
你闪掉
干的就赚翻了
真的是这样就够了
好啦
那其实本来这集想要再讲一点
关于事况的
但我觉得事况也没什么特别要讲
因为我该讲就讲完了
其实基本上恒大
就是现在被找来当一个借口理由
然后其实我认为
就算没有恒大这件事情
其实市场也是可以很轻松的去拿
Delta病毒啊
或是FED跟ECB
可能要去
去tapper这件事情
然后来当成是一个修正的借口
其实真的有太多的东西
可以拿来当一个修正理由
特別是現在其實以台股來講
我必須得說
現在我覺得台股有很多東西
是屬於還蠻便宜的
然後美股的東西
其實本來就是跟台股
是在不同的範疇
具體來說台股你用本益比去估價
美國的一堆標的
你不可以用本益比估價
因為它沒有earning
它根本沒有賺錢
但是如果說你用相對的
就是過往的可能河流圖
或是跟同業去比價之類的
其實美股現在也不是說
真的有到很便宜這樣子
所以其實用任何理由去修正
我覺得都合理
真的都是合理
那一樣如果說你是有做好資金控管
你不是什麼在三頂就一單全部打進去的
那你現在其實就會有很多的機會
就是一個東西你願意在
ASML在800多的時候大家都說要追
那之後疊到700疊到600
奇怪了變便宜人怎麼不敢買了
所以如果說你自己有幫自己做出一些戰略眾生
就是剛剛前面講的很重要
你不要都是0跟1
就是可能0跟100%
那這樣子大家先試看看
特別是如果你是比較菜的
我相信應該會獲得就是蠻多新的啟發
那我们进入Q的部分
第一位这个Masa Herohan
他说不管黑色星期一
回听才能走更远
那回听回听就对了
先恭喜主委当爸
再来五星推报
养小孩和股市有个相同的点
就是纪律
所以主委一定可以把小孩带得很好
但也别忘了妈妈这时候也是需要被关心的
在哺乳期
妈妈有时会有乳腺阻塞的问题
造成妈妈跟婴儿的不适感
祝主委全家幸福安康
三子老司机路过
所以是大学长
三个小孩
那恭喜你啊
一定是过得很幸福吧
那我自己是想要至少两个
所以对
就之后会用力的赶上这样
那确实啊
我觉得在生了小孩之后
会更加的去理解母亲这个角色
她在一个家庭扮演的
那个重量是多少
就是
当然你小时候就很常会洗脑吧
母亲想什么月亮一样
干什么唱歌嘛
可是实际上
你真的有了这个老婆
老婆帮你生了个小孩之后
那个感觉是完全完全不一样
然后对自己的家人的感受
其实也是就是整个会改变
就像人家讲什么养儿方知父母
那种听起来很熟透很无聊的
可是你真的自己体验过才知道这样
所以真的天下的爸妈们都辛苦了
下面因为这个台北唐葫芦说五星吹爆
艾大你好
那你之前说要看分析报告
自己只要决定相信谁
采用什么样的策略
就可以省一些时间
我的问题是应该要怎么对答案呢
即便看对方向也不代表
涨或跌的原因
就是我当初选择的那个
想知道要怎么样校正自己的选择
那另外也有听到
不要为涨或跌找理由的说法
这样是不是按上面的概念相冲突呢
谢谢
其实刚好这集又在讲这个
其实每次都很巧
我发誓我真的没有先读QA
就是有时候
不知道可能大家想知道的东西
我自己也感应的到在撒小的
就刚好会讲到这样
那要怎么样对答案呢
其实只有一个方法可以对答案
就是你到底有没有赚钱
就是你的报酬率
还记得我们上一集
上上集的QA最后一位
就是说什么家人给他一笔钱
然后他拿去投资的
那我有跟他讲一件事
就说其实直接看绩效就好了
就像你不会想听
你买的基金经理人
跟你讲多少故事
为什么他买的东西多有梦
除非你是神经病
你才想听这个
你投资他就是因为
他绩效好
你才会投资他
所以为什么当一个基金
有很大的draw down
就是他在下跌的时候回土太多
这对基金很伤
即便他报酬很好
可是他只要在下跌
可能会赔掉很多钱
那很多这种
买基金的人就会选择赎回
就他受不了
他就直接砍掉
所以要去注意这个终挡
然后去注意这个报酬率的原因
就是因为这样
因为这个散户们要看这个
那其实你可以把它想成
你自己就是这个基金操盘人
就是你终究你进市场的目的
就是什么
就是赚钱嘛
你并不是什么进市场
然后去跟人家辩论比赛
要比谁变赢嘛
就是我们两个去讨论一个标的
这个某伺服器类股
为什么这个Intel跟AMD
到底谁的这个伺服器的
这个晶片做的比较好
你不是要去变一个输赢嘛
你就直接跟我讲说
你后来是买intel还是买amd
然后你哪一个赢
谁赚比较多钱
这个就是结果
所以我们要看的就是结果
而不是说什么
一个论述是对的是错的
但一个论述它是很重要的
就是为什么买进这个标的
一定有它的故事
只是最后面要去验证
这个到底是对还错的时候
其实就是直接看分数就好
所以这是一个
我觉得可以用结果论
来看事情的地方
那再来就是你讲说什么
不要帮涨跌找理由
对因为涨跌找理由
這件事情是一樣
就剛剛節目裡面有提到
你可以找
但是終究要解決的問題是
所以你要怎麼辦
因為你的理由找對找錯
沒有意義
你說現在跌到底是FED
還是ECB
還是恆大
還是其實在跌華龍
還是其實跌什麼
搞不好什麼
現在習近平正在做什麼事情
台海要有危機了
各種誇張的劇本
還是現在其實這媽的
美國之所以那天會跳空大跌
是因為51區的外星人跑出來
然後華爾街先知道了
就不重要
因為跌就跌了
那跌的時候你要幹嘛
就算你知道理由
那所以呢
除非你今天是
举例来说
你是直接买到了恒大的债券
那当然是例外
这个不只是找理由
这个算是
因为它直接对你的标的造成冲击
可是有些东西就是
怎么讲
你没有发生钱
你是没有办法知道
就像我们不可能知道
明天是涨是跌
那如果你手上就是没有直接
曝显到举例来说恒大的东西
那请问一下
你有必要
因为你看到恒大的新闻
就直接O in O out
就会很奇怪
因为那个逻辑上就不对的
但如果说你反过来是
你觉得目前的事况真的不是太好
外面的消息很多
所以因为这样子
你要去调整你的部位
即便这个消息
你也不确定是真是假
但没关系
反正重点就是你要做什么
所以其实答题的重点
是在你要做什么
而不是你找的这个理由是什么
因为你找的理由是什么
其实根本不重要
你如果看多
就会发现有太多的理由
大家找了之后
后来是打脸的
所以根本就不重要
就是理由本身可以看
可以做
但是如果你没有搭配
后续的动作的话
那其实找理由这件事情
就变得是一个无效的动作
大概是我要表达的东西是这样
好下面一个徐满
他说旺旺好喵喵
英俊好可爱
又是徐满
徐满好像出现两三次了吧
不是啦
如果说你想要跟我聊天的话
你干脆直接来视讯我好了
他说忘了还有谢英俊
谢英俊是我的猫咪
他说想问一下来大
投资一些自己觉得有趣的标的
会占所有资金的多少
会投什么标的
那再来就是另外称赞一下来大
发餐看起来蛮好吃的
拍食物的功力有增加
比上次那个烤肉好太多了
那最後做Aida全家平安
艾寶沒開眼笑
秋口繼續可愛PS
Aida有要出火柴人版
Aida牽秋口的T恤嗎
雖然知道你不會出
但還是想問
他講的是我之前那本書的
那個作者圖
我自己畫的
那本來那個天下是講說
要不要把它做成T恤
後來我想想覺得太麻煩就算了
那你前面講說
投有趣的東西會占資金的多少
基本上你講的應該是
我的那一種就是買氣氛的吧
比方說像GoGoro
我就买气氛这样
那个都会占资金很小很小的一部分
因为基本上我不期待它为我带来
比方说很大的报酬
然后以及它也不会在
我很正式的这个资产配置里面
所以像这种东西啊
我买很多库玩页
你知道我库玩页怎么管理吗
就想说你那个标的
你妈的四百多档
跟百货公司一样
你怎么管理
其实不用管理啊
就是你一段时间就去看
用这个损益去排列
亏最多的就把它砍掉
亏最多的我就不要了这样
或者是有些亏
但是因为它是很好玩的东西
就留着这样
基本上那个有点像是好玩而已
就是我手上有一些收藏品这样
我知道很奇怪
有些人收藏什么公仔嘛
什么熊熊嘛
我也觉得你们很奇怪
那我就喜欢收藏标的
类似这样
所以重心还是会放在自己
有在关注的那个核心级档
因为如果你分散到太多档
假设说你是平均分散
那你不如直接买ETF
下面一位谢梦公
他说欢迎收听古爱
我是谢梦公
那五星吹棒好棒棒
留言留了五次都没有被念到
没关系留第六次就会被念到了
感谢来大陆之优质好节目
这个月的13号是推荐我古来的
哥哥谢梦兄的生日
不是你哥哥真的他妈叫谢梦兄吗
这什么鬼名字
然后说虽然已经过了
可以帮我祝他生日快乐吗
然后这个哥哥生日快乐
然后另外这个月19号
也是我哥哥的女朋友凯西的生日
那虽然也已经过了
但是还是可以帮我祝他生日快乐吗
好凯西生日快乐
然后说最后这个月25号是我的生日
可以请来大爷祝我生日快乐吗
那感谢主委赞叹主委PS建议主委
可以再帮小主委生一个弟弟或妹妹
从小有个玩伴陪伴会过得很快乐
先祝这个
妈你智障
你是谢梦公
靠腰
那我不就祝你谢梦公
25号生日快乐
干妈你要我祝你生日快乐
你要留自己的名字啊
然后说这个
从小有个玩伴会很快乐
没有
像我自己
我跟我姐
还有我妹的关系是还蛮差的
就从小就很差
我们是处于那种战斗的状态
会抢玩具
然后会互相去告状那一种
我直到大学以后
我才比较喜欢我姐姐
所以未必就是
你生一个弟妹
然后他们可以很融洽这样
虽然对啦
就是在这个纠纷的过程之中
也不是说什么
我真的很讨厌我姐姐
就像把她杀掉之类的
就只是很常有吵架
可是确实好像是还蛮玩的
我自己的想法是
我不是为了要
他们这样觉得很好玩
干我屁事
我就只是生了
我自己觉得很好玩你知道
像有些人生小孩觉得
这个小孩要对我们负责
对我们家长负责
没有我只是觉得
你很好玩
我才把你生下来这样
然后我尽可能的供应你
所以我不会觉得
你对我有什么责任
所以你跟你的这个
姐姐或是弟弟妹妹相處的怎麼樣幹也不干我屌事我會盡可能的去維繫這樣可是實際上就是我自己想要有一個这样子的家庭所以我去做这样的决定听起来好像有点自私没错吧可是实际上本来就这样啊
你生小孩
你就不可以先去问你小孩
所以我会被生下来
所以
我不会要求说
他们一定要怎么样之类的
但当然啦
我希望他们是很融洽的
就至少不要像
我小时候跟我姐我妹这样
就处于一个那种
类似那种战争的关系
好 下面因为这个梦公老公
他说我爱梦公当我老公
这一定又是一个他妈臭屌
他说想请问一下
埃大对于成长股会怎么样估值
因为小弟
就是小弟
对于成长股都是用这个FORPS来估值
那同时也参考埃大推荐的
雅虎来套分析师的数据
但又常常会发现
有些公司的平均PSR差距很大
怕导致平均下来的结果
或许是高估或是低估
那还是其实没有这样的问题
所以想问一下
埃大会怎么样去看PS的平均值
那假设之后联准会开始紧缩
埃大会怎么样去计算呢
例如一间公司目前的股价
就算2022的PSR是50
那历史平均是54
看起来是便宜没错
但考虑宽松进去的话
挨大会怎么给
感谢挨大
那如果挨大看不懂我在问什么的话
可以直接回答挨大自己
怎么去估成长股的
谢谢
好其实这一位这个梦公老公
他讲的话
你就知道他是有在用心
首先就是他是用forward来估
你知道这个就已经赢过
大概一大堆人了
一大堆人估值都是用过去的数据估
那没有什么太大的意义
你是要用未来来估
然后再来就是他很明确的知道
成長股要用PS
股意你用PE
股不出來
你會股出要嘛就是什麼天文書枝
要嘛就是什麼
就是負值之類的
所以你要用PS來看是沒錯的
那你講了這個
就到底怎麼樣股才正確
我必須跟你講
沒有正確答案
真的沒有正確答案
你說聯準會收攏之後
就一定會跌嗎
那我請你去看一下
上一次
上一次去縮減資產負債表的時候
你去找一下歷史數據
你看一下每股是漲還是跌
最後面還是是漲的
所以不是说资金收容或是升息
就怎么样股市局一定要跌
我觉得那可能就是一个短线的冲击
可是长线来说
还是回归一家公司会成长
就是怎么讲你投资
你可能会因为一些大盘
或是系统性的危机状况
这个标的会杀高
会喷低还是说怎么样
可是实际上最后面
就还是回归个股的表现
当然我们说大盘跌的时候
覆潮之下无完软
大家都会下去这样
可是最后面你会发现
那些优先涨回来的都不是错涨的
你知道像去年大家讲说
这些SARS公司干是涨啥小
然后最后面发现成长超暴力
就等到真的你看到数字之后
你才知道为什么
那市场是很有效率的
就要提早反应
但不是完全的有效率
这是为什么大家才赚得到α
如果说是完全有效率
那基本上大家都不会有这个
获利的空间的
然后你说
好举例来说
这个一个公司2022PSR50
那历史平均54
对你可以直接用历史平均去看
可是我觉得
你现在应该很难找到
就是用这个数字去推
然后是比历史平均还低的
因为几乎所有的标的都在高档
我不知道你怎么样找到的
所以光是它比历史均价还低这件事情
我觉得就还蛮屌的
因为这个东西应该是比较少见的
然后再来就是说
我自己的建议
就是你可以去参考同业的一个估值
有一个网站好像叫什么
Guru Focus
它可以去帮你列出说
一家公司
它的PS或是PE
在美国同样的族群里面
它是排行在哪里的
但这个东西列出来也未必是有效的
举例来说像Snow或是之前的Zoom
你排出来它就是整个市场
就是PR99最贵的
可是东西就还是会继续涨
所以也不是说什么
它今天来到一个估值上缘
它就没有办法继续涨
因为估值上缘
那天花板是可以拿来顶破的
你知道吗
就像那个原油起火的时候
跌到零
大家以为零就是地板
就是地下室
下面有地下室
所以我觉得
这也是我们刚才前面讲的
其实投资并没有那么简单
我基本面看对就会赚钱
重点是市场有没有青睐这个东西
举例来说现在市场上有一大堆的
就我们讲那种value stocks
就是你可以用PE去分析的
然后可能是比方说在道琼的
这个范围里面的公司
那为什么它可能就是比较不会涨
它的体质不好吗也没有
就只是可能现在市场的风气
就是比较喜欢这些成长股
但是搞不好之后会有这种
所谓的价值复辟
你知道其实很多价值投资人
一直在喊这个价值扶辟
喊了好几年没有发生的
但你也不知道会不会之后就发生
然后你后来会发现
就是可能你回头看
几年后回头看
哇靠我竟然在跟人家讨论说
一个公司妈的PS ratio
干50我还敢买
因为搞不好到那个时候
整个市场的风格已经不一样了
就大家不会去买这样的东西
所以这真的是很难说
所以我来说估值是一门艺术
而不是就是绝对的科学
所以你目前在做的事情
我觉得没有什么太大问题
就只是你要去承担胜败而已
因为怎么讲
就像是
举例来说
我们两个都是估值高手好了
那现在我们两个办一场比赛
终究会有一个人赢吧
就是我们两个都是估值高手
可是我就是买到比你会长的
就有点类似这样子
你现在你已经可以达到
第一个你会知道要怎么找资料
第二个你知道要用forward
第三个你会看历史河流图
那如果再加上你会看同侪
以及你会分析公司的成长性的话
你已经做到所有能做的事情了
接下来就只是考验你的眼光
你知道有些人就是没有眼光
他可以算出很多数字或什么
他就选到一个市场不会喜欢的东西
那要怎么办
其实也不能做什么
好 下面一位这个不吃早餐
他说睡吃早午餐
那今晚我想来一点
韩式辣味锅贴加酸辣汤跟甜不辣加汤
什么样的人会甜不辣加汤
下面一位这个好好理财
叫做五星吹捧
从去年12月刚入股市
郑老师大多头的时代
有姓金女友介绍股癌
那学到相对安全的投资观念
那经历过阳明33块
30块买33块卖
那群创抱过一座山
当冲航运陪报
那买过合硕
联勇不会动的股票
但买到还涨的台信金
那最后发现
比较喜欢还涨的股票
那慢慢来比较好
抓买卖时机
那恭喜爱大宝宝出生
祝宝宝平安健康长大
爱大全家天天快乐
秋口永远可爱
好 感谢你
那你刚刚讲到说什么
这个联勇是不会动的股票
那联勇超会动的
合硕才是属于
可能比较不会动的
那也恭喜你有找到
适合自己的方法
真的真的最重要的
下面有这个Dog999Dog
他说诸位五星推爆再说
那五星推爆主委
先恭喜小诸位的诞生
那我这个中二三宝霸
不是中二
中年三宝霸
拍赛
那很能体会你节目分享的爸爸金
希望主委可以多生几个
这样小主委才有办
那过到这个很重要
那言归正传
虽然去年底才开始听
也近十个月了
那这些急速让我老蔡基的观念变得更好
希望慢慢的我会把以前输的奶粉钱都赢回来
非常感谢主委的无私的分享
那某一集谈到
不要预设立场顺势而为的观念
我很喜欢
在我的停力停损上面
这观念帮忙很多
但在布局或是超悬部署的上面
我还抓不到重点
因为不预设立场
也会少了些热情
可以请主委开示一下吗
另外还想问
2022网通的趋势
主委认为如何呢
若要布局上游
有建议哪些原件或题材吗
最后很多人都把鼓埃当助眠
我刚好相反
每天都期待周三周六新的一集
听节目陪伴我慢跑
不管室内室外跑
算一算
今年也陪伴我400公里以上了
热血了
那这个
我先谢谢这个地方三宝霸
今天有两个三宝霸
这个都是在贡献社会的
非常非常的涌健
那你说这个不预设立场顺势而为
这个是非常非常重要的观念
但是我觉得这是建立在
当然你不可能完全没有立场
这是绝对的
你买一个标的
一定是因为你喜欢他
只是你买他之后
重点是你去抓那个感觉
就是你买他一定是你很喜欢他
可是你不可以喜欢到晕船
就是狂买
买到那妈有一天
人家突然联络你说
来开董事会
靠腰
变董事了
越跌越买
买到变董事
这可能就不太好了
所以我们要讲的就是说
你今天做好一个分析之后
如果说我们用
这个交女朋友的案例
就是你一定要先知道
他在做什么
他的兴趣是什么
他家人在干嘛
什么大家都先知道
虽然有些人可能
有些在意
有些不在意
可是你至少先做一个
全盘的滴滴
你要先研究人家
那你研究完之后
你可能就是要进入
不预设立场的部分的
就是你前面一定都会先做研究
就是这个是有立场的部分
可是后面就会进入
不预设立场的部分
就是如果跟他相处之中
对我研究完
他真的是一个超级好人
这个人如果他妈放到市场上
一定是大家都要抢断
跟他结婚的
可是他跟我相处就是
就是不适合
他就是他妈嘴巴超臭的
干那个就是那个什么
有那个那叫什么
那个扁条线结石啊
有些人有扁条线结石
没有定期去把它洗出来
干啊讲话都超臭的受不了
或是一些小毛病
就这个是你当时可能研究
就是没有发现的
然后你在相处过程之中
你才发现的
这些东西可能真的就影响到
你的感受到很深
让你真的受不了
所以不预测立场
你就不适合的
就不适合
所以就有点类似这样
我一个东西我研究的很深
我买了
可是最后面呢
因为我们终究
还是要回到核心
你来投资是要干嘛
你是来赚钱的
不然你是来干嘛的
所以你就来赚钱的吗
一个标的买了就是不会赚钱
你就要开始去思考了
我要继续等他吗
还是这个机会成本已经太高了
我明明看好的其他东西都会动
就这个不会动
所以我就不要再去预设立场
可能就是市场不喜欢或什么的
其实到最后你可以把很多东西都赖给市场不喜欢
因为市场太诡谓莫变了
我们真的不知道
就是可能一个东西今天热门
明天会不会继续热门
或者说一个很赚钱的公司
为什么市场就不喜欢
那个是找不到理由的
所以你把它交给市场去决定
如果你发现它跟你走的方向不一样
那你就把它出掉
是可以这样做
但当然你也可以选择
我就是爱到咖善死
我就他妈继续蹲蹲到底这样
好然后第二个问题问说
网通的趋势我认为怎么样
就我觉得网通会是一个很重要的主轴
因为网通算是今年的受害股
就缺货的受害股
缺货有受惠股
就那些涨价的
那受害股就是什么
工业电脑网通
因为他们可能在这个拉货的竞争力
可能没有比其他人好之类
所以因为缺料他组不出东西
就没有办法赚钱
所以你看到网通很多
在今年的表现可能是比较普通一点
但如果说缺料状况解决
我觉得工业电脑跟网通都可以看
然后今天其实我们应该都有发现
就如果说你是比较细腻的人
在每次大跌不要就是
手机关起来不要看了
电脑不要看盘了
其实每次的大跌
更是要找机会的时候
如果说你有仔细看
就会发现今天有什么强势族群
今天CCL超强
三个联帽 台药 台光电都很强
就是要么就涨要么就没什么跌
那再来就是网通的部分
起机跟台阳
太陽我覺得有點像主力鼓
有點硬拉的味道
甚至是嘎空
那奇蹟呢
也是算是過去表現沒那麼好
可是今天也是非常的強勢
那再來就是往這個server端去的
包含說晶片
然後還有這個PCB的部分
像博智跟金像電
這也是廣義上的網通
他們也是屬於今天比較硬的
就是大家都在大跌
它沒什麼跌的
這些東西你可以稍微注意看看
那我覺得網通跟工業電腦之後
應該都還是有些機會啦
其实应该说整个台国市场
对
当然我们现在看到一个下沙
我们看到美股下沙
我们也不知道会杀几天或什么的
可是在基本面分析上
我并没有觉得说
这是一个世界末日
所以我自己还会持续去看
有没有更多的机会
好那这期节目就到这边
就这样拜